noi siamo
veloci
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a questo podcast
che faccio con queste due persone
fantastiche
oggi è la puntata numero 8 ok siete
contenti io no
a volte la stessa cosa ha fatto da un
bambino da un adulto può assumere
significati totalmente diversi il tema
del gioco per esempio ha da sempre avuto
un'importanza sociale pedagogica ed
evolutiva in quello che il percorso di
formazione di un giovane individuo
eppure qualcosa di così naturale
prezioso può trasformarsi in una
dipendenza una schiavitù fino a
diventare un vero e proprio debole
volevo soltanto
ipotizzare a lezione concerto benissimo
la società nella quale viviamo è una
società che ci spinge costantemente
continuamente ad essere vincenti chi
perde è da eliminare chi perde rimane in
panchina e purtroppo esistono giochi per
grandi che sono fatti apposta per farti
giocare sempre senza vincere mai nome
alessandro gambardella professione ex
croupier a londra è originario di un
piccolo paesino campano ha poi vissuto a
palermo liverpool e londra nella sua
attività da croupier ne ha viste davvero
tante e innamorato della city è rimasto
a londra per dieci anni per poi tornare
alla sua città di origine per
avvicinarsi alla famiglia e super fan di
moto da corsa appena tempo libero salta
in sella e arriva in costiera al momento
lavora in un negozio di animali e il suo
piatto preferito sono i friarielli
impossibili da trovare allora specie in
inglese liverpool follow up sono
fratelli
per dirti primaria
vogliamo fare entrare alessandro
by alessandro grazie per essere dei
nostri grazie a voi per l'invito ci
spieghi come si diventa gruppi e
innanzitutto con un minimo almeno di
passione per il gioco con una scuola ce
ne sono diverse anche in italia sono dei
corsi di formazione fondamentalmente ti
insegnano un po le regole del gioco come
gestire il gioco come condurlo e
soprattutto come prestare attenzione a
quello che succede al giocatori tipo
arbitro un pochino anche un pochino sì
quanto dura lo studio più o meno 3 4
mesi renzi però non è lunghissima ok poi
arriva il momento del cuore tubo parti
giusto perché in realtà da dove abiti tu
una piccola città tra napoli e salerno
ok non c'era e da nocera arrivi a
palermo ok palermo perché c'era la
all'epoca ma forse anche oggi più
importante scuola per gruppi e a palermo
pazzesco i giochi diciamo che impari i
fondamentali sono la roulette e il
blackjack poi c'è un gioco si chiama
three card poker che è una versione da
casinò del del poker pro fatto con tre
carte la roulette quella lì che gira che
l'anci la biglietto e poi ci stanno
tutte le persone che nei film hanno
quella specie di plancia dove puntano le
fiji ok ma tu devi tra tutte quelle cose
beccare un numero se c'è questo il gioco
c'è di con mille euro su il 23 in rosso
esatto e spero che esca 20 rosso e mi sa
che jackie perché sai che il rosso il 23
davvero
bene verso tutti sgamato
il gioco quindi non è un discorso di
talento e puramente
fortuna e basta si fortuna probabilità e
basta nient'altro c'è gente che ci ha
perso i miliardi o che arrivano da
raccontaci una serata tipo di un
croupier allora una giornata tipo di
svegli con molto comodo non prima delle
due del pomeriggio che un po l'alba per
noi
aspetti le otto alle dieci di sera
quando comincia il tuo turno fi 8 ore
belle di fila al lavoro dalle 10 di sera
6 di mattina
c'è gente che ancora le 6 del mattino
gioca gente che viene alle 6 del mattino
che si sveglia con quel pensiero per
andare a giocare la gente che rimane lì
dalla notte prima
la gente viene il pomeriggio e se ne va
il giorno dopo rimane vita la notte
prima cosa vuol dire che dorme del
casinò se non dormono mai perché non ci
sono gli orologi si sa le finestre tutti
oscurate assurdo non sai se giorno notte
se sono passate due ore o sei da quando
sei lì quindi ti fai 8 ore 8 ore con se
sei fortunato
diverse pause da una ventina di minuti
poi dipende un po da livello del casinò
dove lavori quanti soldi vedi in quelle
otto ore un mare non penso siano
quantificabili
poi di nuovo dipende sempre da dove ci
sono due diverse categorie di casinò c'è
il casinò la battaglia quello che è un
po l'equivalente del nostro bimbo più
accessibile a tutti si esatto e poi ci
sono i casinò di alto livello
dove
entra solo gente diciamo che si profila
ma che siamo permette rientrerà perché
tu non puoi entrare così se vuoi in
questi casi no no a parte che ormai con
tutti i controlli che ci sono si creano
un profilo all'ingresso in quasi tutti i
casinò per capire un po il tuo livello
di spesa quanto ti puoi permettere
non tanto per il casinò quanto per i
giocatori questo livello diciamo più
alto al quale tu sei questo giro diciamo
più alto nel quale si è entrato non era
a palermo no io ho lavorato solo in
inghilterra ok quindi disposto in
inghilterra è un tavolo medio quanti
soldi aveva sopra mezzo milione
nei livelli alti
sul mezzo milione caduto poi scappare
con tutte le fiches trasferiti da
qualche beneficio sono
conosciuta come è una bella sacca di
plastica in un paese ricercata in un
altro casino anche cambiare
esattamente così le fiji ovviamente sono
impossibili a contraffare spagna bella
all'interno del casinò cesano
difficilissima alcune hanno addirittura
dei microchip all'interno per la
tracciabilità ci sono delle fiches che
valgono 5 10 25 mila sterline 100.000
sterline addirittura nell'ultimo casinò
dove lavorato ne avevamo una da un
milione
l'hai mai vista usare hearts e cioè
uno ha puntato una fiction milione si è
fermato solo perché è il massimo che gli
hanno consentito hanno detto basta se è
questo che ha puntato un milione e cioè
vincolo caso vince il doppio no cosa al
gioco che giocava lui e ha vinto o ha
perso la giocato diverse volte a volte
ha vinto portava perso cioè il
meccanismo funziona io sono un cliente
non vado ambo credo una cassa di
ingresso cioè pago un milione e loro mi
danno un pezzettino di plastica e poi
quando esco ieri do un pezzettino di
plastico meditando un milione e si fa
pagare un milione
[Musica]
base
avere una transizione da un milione di
euro così
come
quanto appresso
un certo
qual è la puntata maggiore che tu abbia
mai visto questo da un milione c'è il
massimo previsto è di chi era in giro e
l'arco di due giorni questa persona ha
perso in una giornata e mezzo 11 milioni
di sterline
che ti dia e ti dirò il loro si alzano
tranquilli e sereni
beh ho capito se punti così tanto mi
sento di dire che avrà una vita cioè
sarà come per noi dire oh mi compra un
gratta e vinci da un euro ma nessuno ha
mai fatto avance di più con fronte
perfetto io sicuramente vado a palermo
vado a farmi questa scuola vado tutto
quanto affittato a londra da mister 11
milioni persi sguardo languido mentre
gli dò le carte ea quel punto io divento
una moglie trofeo
ha capito che ha detto i soldi non fanno
la felicità
no no no ecco perché gli voglio
guadagnare facilissima cioè non è che
voglio spaccarmi la schiena
avere una pro un approccio anche etico
al denaro e ora parleremo anche di
quello spiace che la tua vita ti ha
portato ad essere così superficiale
disse quello che fattura sui sentimenti
dai per favore almeno io almeno utilizzo
delle forti in maniera coerente e
pertanto l'uso a favore mio detto ciò
etica come ci si pone nel momento in cui
si approccia effettivamente a quella che
per certi versi dopo un po diventa più
di una semplice passione più di un
semplice interesse ma diventa una
dipendenza diciamo che non me ne voglia
la categoria dei medici ma è un po come
fare il dottore c'è chi si distacca o
reagisci così nel senso che ti vedi
queste persone con problematiche perché
poi diventano problematica e lo ignori
oppure ci metti un po di compassione un
bel po di compassione e cerchi un po non
di tracciare la linea perché alla fine è
sempre il giocatore che
certo non puoi fare niente se lui rimane
la gioca io non sono nessuno però magari
cerchi costantemente di riportarlo
all'attenzione
[Musica]
che stai facendo poi ce n'è ancora
riesci ma la dinamica può essere la
invito ad alzarsi anche e non è scortese
però per un cliente cioè al di là del
fatto che sia chiaramente una cosa
compassionevole quello è un po la zona
grigia parte ci sono tanti corsi di
aggiornamento che si fanno con cadenza
annuale
proprio per individuare i soggetti un po
più fragili certo che per di un milione
magari tira uno schiaffo al tavolo è
normale uno invece tira uno schiaffo al
tavolo si gira male
comincia a sudare e di un po gli occhi
così perché ci sono anche reazioni di
questo di questa violenza
a me 1 mascherato addosso ad
acconciare i matti continuità e se presa
sì sì con me proprio personalmente to
chiaramente non hai reagito
no io in realtà all'inizio pensavo fosse
cocktail sai perché non guardavo lui
direttamente quindi mi sono solo sentito
in fresca
poi quando ho collegato la scena ho
detto ma ho chiamato il mio ispettore
perché poi vicino ogni tavolo c'è un
ispettore che controlla uno più tavoli
tutto credo che il signore mi abbia
sputato addosso
lui è stato fermato dalla sicurezza
cacciato però la mia reazione è stata
proprio nulla se io avessi reagito io
perdo il lavoro ma soprattutto i toast
avendo a che fare una persona che non
sta molto bene
risse tra giocatori e tantissime per le
fiches giocate quest'anno giocata io no
questa è mia non è vero poi il casinò
credo che sia abbia più telecamere di
una banca di un cavo c'è ma veramente si
possono vedere a volte nei tavoli quelle
che sono le fiches che sono state
giocate di tutto e una domanda che
voglio risvoltare quella di prima
impositivo perdono e ti sputano vincolo
tantissimo e ti lasciano una bella
manciata
perché ci si arriva al tavolo vicino
voglia di limo nar melo poi perché dico
io ti amo per tutta la mia vita il piano
è che tu non mi devi di minare proprio
anello al dito mangia più grande e più
grossa che ricevuto 50.000 sterline
però non sono personali e deve dividere
milano con tutto lo sto cazzato basta
scuse e tra l'altro sono passate credo
siano le uniche mangia al mondo le
passate e quindi poi fa così
non ci sono telecamere la circolare si
scusa scusa dono meraviglioso e la
mancia quindi media a serata con te che
entra 30 16 dipende
150 50 euro io ti allungo 50.000
sterline pacchetti entrano 100 euro più
o meno si la proporzione è così quel ma
non ci credo ma scusa ma nemmeno se il
cliente fa la richiesta di dire questi
voglio che siano tutti i suoi
assolutamente no può aspettare che esce
finisce il turno e prova a mettere in
tasca ma se hai un minimo di etica
professionale
ecco se non ce l'ha invece i veti
vitalissimo scusa
sto cercando di fare ragazzi tutto un
calcolo e un'analisi su questa cosa c'è
mai stato una volta in cui hanno cercato
di corrompere di certo tantissimo come
funziona il giocatore alla fine lo sa
perché il giocatore conosce il gioco
meglio di me che faccia il croupier però
in quel momento
dimentica che io non ho influenza sul
gioco quindi preso dall'euforia il
desiderio non so la malattia forse anche
ci prova in tutti i modi a se guardi una
roulette capisci che è impossibile
prevedere il numero la sezione la fascia
di numeri il colore ci sono dei diamanti
lungo il secondo bordeaux dove
praticamente cade la pallina che ti
fanno rimbalzare la pallina in maniera
completamente casuale la pallina grande
più o meno così tu hai una mano per
lanciarla in un canale
quindi io non ti posso veramente aiutare
eppure c'è stata gente che ha cercato di
corrompersi alla roulette almeno uno al
giorno cioè ci sono come come ti
approcciano fai uscire questo numero si
avvicinano perché facevano anche
microfoni ovviamente oltre alle
telecamere il prossimo numero e questo
ti do lo so una cifra hicks bassi quando
della puntata la corruzione più grande
la corruzione più grande mi hanno
chiesto di cambiare una carta al tavolo
pagando di quanto eventualmente credo
10.000 sterline
la puntata era bella grande ma era era
la cosa era veramente impossibile che io
io ma ma a segno la carta ma che cazzo
stanno facendo qui invece c'è mai stato
un tuo collega che si è fatto
portare magari l'hanno beccato sì sì no
è raccontaci scusa tanto non parlano
italiano queste persone
vabbè senza nome e senza mai non sei tu
non stop no no
diciamo che hanno provato in più
occasioni a mettersi d'accordo anche tra
tra gruppi e stesso magari qualcuno che
lavorava in un altro casino cioè io
vengo li faccio finta di fare il
giocatore e cerchiamo un po in che modo
si può cambiare se il gioco è casuale
non si può infatti li hanno beccati
credo alla prima volta poi se ci sono
state volte precedenti dove l'hanno
fatta franca volo abbiamo un mazzo di
carte in un mai capito quanto perché
mazzarri sono blu che io proprio solo a
neanch'io mai occasioni sono tutte
uguali ai suoi altri un mazzi ma tutti
dello stesso colore sono indistinguibili
quando è l'ultima volta che mi scatta un
mazzo sono diversi anni sente un po un
po l'attrazione mi stanno richiamano
perché siccome carrello che gli ha dato
un'idea ragazzi questa è la verità le
ultime carte sempre a terra ha verso di
te
dato il basso vedere e poi le unisce
così in modo tale che presidente di
nessuna carta insomma mi fai proprio che
si uniscono
mi passi quella metà di marzo che avanza
voglio provare a fare queste cose scusa
e quante volte di farlo ogni casinò alle
sue procedure che più o meno sono tutti
simili nel senso che c'è sempre questo
[Musica]
cercando di fare perché se lo vedo da
lui sembra così facile
la brava to
sembrava così facile certo anche quando
guarda guarda parte sparata ma guarda
guarda ce l'ho fatta
dalla mar da allora questo qui si chiama
shuffle ctia fall e ogni casinò decide
di farne di solito 3 4 5 e quasi tutti i
casinò lo intervallano con una cosa che
si chiama arif all ossia una volta
finito lo shuffle fai questo
lo stripping e black jack si fa di
solito poco 14 o con 6 o addirittura con
8 mazzi di carte quanto ci mettiamo
mescolare essere velocissimo perché
quando ti fermi per di soldi e il casinò
non lo vuole ma scusa ti faccio una
domanda ma i gruppi e le percentuali
sulle vittorie o ha uno stipendio fisso
no uno stipendio e le mangia quando salì
ai manager il manager prendono i bonus
ma nessuno prende percentuali sulle
vittorie giusto per capire lo stipendio
medio in gruppi e quindi si aggira
intorno con tutte le mance e quant'altro
quando sono partito alla mia prima
esperienza come
principiante guadagnava sulle mille
sterline al liverpool però quando sono
sceso a londra il mio stipendio è
praticamente raddoppiato quasi il
proprio sotto le 2000 con un po di
esperienza lo stipendio medio è
2005 faccio una domanda romantiche
adesso cioè se chi lavora tutte le notti
la tua vita sentimentale la tua vita con
gli amici la tua vita proprio non esiste
diciamo che spesso capita che i
croupier frequentino altri gruppi e gli
atleti postare d'amore si è ammirato
scusa a me fatto quella scala di cuori
sembra unire bravi se poi li ha
rilanciati il microfono sulla fronte e
vedo quanto sanguini si è un po di
storia con colleghi quelle di altri
casinò dello stesso casinò cosa che
invece dopo dieci anni che ha spinto poi
a staccare ha sicuramente gli affetti la
famiglia gli amici o è un po anche quel
tipo di vita che si lo puoi fare
guadagni bene
per arrivi a un punto dove dici di un po
decidere che cosa vuoi fare da grande e
devi decidere che cosa vuoi dalla vita
ho dato priorità ad altre cose ad altra
cosa qual è il tuo rapporto col gioco
invece io l'ho sempre odiato mi ha dato
una noia da giocatore è indescrivibile
che non mi sono mai spiegato perché poi
invece il mio lavoro mi piaceva
tantissimo 11 anni sempre lettore non ho
mai lavorato un giorno perché mi
divertivo trascende la sera andava al
lavoro contentissimo c'è mai stato un
momento nel quale nella tua vita a
quello che sembrava un gioco può in
realtà diventato una roba un pochino più
pericolosa ma nell'ambito lavorativo
che può essere un lavoro pericoloso il
tuo dipende
dalla stupidità della gente nel senso
che ci sono molti colleghi che appunto
magari hanno aspettati fuori dal casinò
con minacce
di aggressione perché magari avevano
perso da qui a definirlo pericoloso il
processo può capitare a chiunque a
questo punto ci sono dei momenti nei
quali ti manca tantissimo quando quasi
tutti i giorni
che sei tornato quando c'era sono quasi
due anni e cosa che ti ferma dal provare
riandare il fatto che credo che sia un
po la natura umana
ti manca sempre quello che non hai
quindi quando ero lì mi mancava quello
che avevo qui quando sono qui mi manca
quello che avevo lì cosa c'è secondo te
alla base della ludopatia alla base
della ludopatia ci possono essere
diverse ragioni credo che la più comune
sia la voglia di avere di più che tra
l'altro è il motivo per cui il casinò
vince sempre cioè tu vai lì ti siedi
giochi se stai vincendo non ti alzi
perché vuoi di più se stai perdendo
perdi fino a quello che poi fino a
quello che hai deciso nella speranza che
ci siamo anche le cure cioè esiste
effettivamente questo immaginario dei
grandi casinò gli abiti pazzeschi le
donne cariche di diamanti ma se ci
pensate esistono invece un sacco di bar
con quelle macchinette del cazzo la
gente sta poi sente un certo punto lo
scroscio di monete che vengono subito
riutilizzate per giocare ancora giocare
ancora giocare allora è un qualcosa che
ovviamente indipendentemente la tua
disponibilità economica cioè il
giocatore o comunque chi ha bisogno di
giocare ha bisogno di un qualcosa
proprio alla base ma tipo quali sono
alcuni profili uno potrebbe essere per
esempio il giocatore che viene perché
vede nel casinò la sua vita sociale la
gente che viene la piuttosto che uscire
con gli amici lui sa magari casinò
sempre lo stesso conosce lo staff
si creano anche delle belle amicizie
anche con giocatori
sono rimasto in ottimi rapporti con
molti giocatori
o questa non so se si vede questo regalo
la signora che veniva giocare per la sua
cultura significava tanto l'era cinese
eravamo tanti anni tanto amici me l'ha
regalata eccolo quanto puntava questa
signora sui 1.000 euro al giorno
importanti però comunque così ha fatto
bene lasciarsela sfuggire dove puntare
più in alto sola cosa che diciamo esiste
un modo sano per approcciarsi al gioco
qual è la percentuale secondo te di
persone che riescono diciamo a
giocare responsabilmente e quelle che
invece allora diciamo che la proporzione
forse tende più verso quelle che non
riescono ad approcciarsi in maniera sana
per una questione statistica ci sono 5
casinò a londra del livello di cui ti
parlavo prima dove si giocano i milioni
e i soldi e quelli per assurdo pur
giocando le cifre più alte sono quelle
più che si certo perché sono quelli che
se lo possono permettere per dire venuto
johnny depp
una sera hanno passato da noi tutta la
squadra del chelsea sono quei profili
che possono avere quel tenore di vita e
non ne risentono cioè per loro è un
gioco invece ci sono più di tremila
casinò in inghilterra dove il profilo
più basso e ci va la persona media pur
essendo minore la puntata in proporzione
cioè si gioca allo stipendio ma voi
siete entrati ma in un casino io entrai
a un bingo se non sbaglio ha vinto io
sono andato per comici trascinarono fare
come era quello di coi numeri a tombole
la tombolata non ho vinto io sono
abbastanza sfigato
al gioco esondata vengo ha vinto anche
ho detto vengo e poi te ne sei andato a
testa bassa che noia che puoi giocare
quella cioè
comprendo caruccio sì qual è il gioco
che crea più dipendenza penso che creino
tutti dipendenza in egual misura credo
che le macchine le antenne siano più
pericolose di qualunque gioco del casinò
di di qualunque ambiente regolato perché
appunto la macchinetta sei tu lì davanti
ci butti un euro 20.000 lo sai solo tu
probabilmente non te ne accorgi perché
sono fa certo in modo tale da tiranti e
tenerti la quelle luci eccetera
qual è il tuo rapporto con la vittoria e
con la sconfitta e lo chiedo non solo a
te alessandro ma tutti quanti i feroci
di questo tavolo no io sono molto
sportivo soprendere benissimo una
sconfitta laccetto anche volentieri a
volte a me piace la competizione a me
piace mettermi in gioco anche nella vita
cioè che quando la vita magari ti porta
a non vincere qualcosa e a dire
soprattutto nella vita penso che sia sì
non dico il momento in cui mi divertono
quello in cui mi impegno di più quando
vedi che le cose magari fanno un po male
dove faccio un po di grinta e ci devi
rifare per forza devi ri puntare in alto
allora io da quando sono piccolo che
vivo in un mondo competitivo
cioè la televisione competizioni
musicali sanremo competizione le scale
se all'inizio devo cercare sempre di
trovare il nero il bianco no allora
vittoria bianco sconfitta nero cioè in
questo momento io ho smesso di avere
completamente un giudizio su quello che
è una sconfitta quello che una vittoria
quella vittoria li non ha significato
come non ha significato la sconfitta è
un fatto è un momento fine non salta è
presente quando da ragazzini a scuola ti
facevano fare la corsa campestre no tu
correvi vicino agli altri la cosa che mi
succedeva sempre se io vedevo qualcuno
correre vicino a me correvo
istintivamente meno veloce ti capisco
perfettamente ho capito quando invece
corro a occhi chiusi corro molto più
veloce c'è quindi la competizione è
sempre
interiore con quello che è il mio
obiettivo di raggiungimento personale
lollo allora io non sono per niente
competitivo infatti quando perdo ne
sbatto
quando vinco era ovviamente lei e cioè
però nel senso ok nel gioco comunque
fece nella vita le sconfitte le prendo
bene perché cerco di imparare da delle
ricadute
le vittorie invece non riesco a
godermela perché penso sempre adesso ci
sarà qualcosa di negativo che succede
subito e raggiungo un traguardo di così
lei però non mi posso fermare qua devo
avere l'ansia di portare questa vittoria
avanti e la coda unar la e poi la
competizione la sento che è brutto da
dire però adesso coi social faccio un
sacco di c'è
comparazione per azione esatto con gli
altri creator che conosco e dico sempre
loro hanno raggiunto questo traguardo
con l'io ancora sono quasi
un po
eviti infatti ci sono giù
giù giù però le sconfitte però le bene
infatti col sorriso certo certo certo io
credo di volermi sempre dire che non
sono competitivo e in realtà che deve
avere uno spirito molto competitivo che
vive malissimo la competizione io facevo
nuoto anche quando vedevo raviggiolo
quando durante le gare vedevo con la
coda dell'occhio qualcuno che il minuto
va vicino automaticamente notavo più
piano infatti io ero bravo col dorso
perché guardavo il soffitto io trovo che
gli sconfitti siano veramente
un'occasione per fare un attimo un punto
non tanto come fallito di dove di dove
hai sbagliato ma di dove vuoi andare
quando poi ti rialzi perché direzioni
sono infinite atm ma la vittoria serve
sempre per correre più veloce ma la
sconfitta serve per segnare la direzione
almeno certo michele che sta scrivendo
una canzone
che tutte le classiche di inserirmi nei
mesi insieme la mia ultima domanda è
stata lanciata ragazzi c'è qualcosa che
volete aggiungere voi che non è stato
detto che è stato aggiunto
michele hai fatto già all in con tutte
le tue domande si è saputo ha pagato se
mandato tipo nei casinò quelli a
montecarlo las vegas
fichi enormi las vegas di montecarlo no
esentato diversi da quelli in cui
lavorava sì anche quelli di las vegas
che sono un po il nostro immaginario
rispetto a quelli di aver lavorato
ultimamente sono una cafonata
cafonata un parco giochi per grandi
tu eri di classe mentre invece così sono
da cafoni io no qual è il casinò più
prestigioso del è vero credo l'ultimo
dove ho lavorato e ti giuro non perché
ci ho lavorato ma è quello dove oltre ad
aver visto le cose più assurde ho visto
proprio l'eleganza e la l'apice di
quello che io posso immaginare come c'è
qualcosa deve dire l'ultima così prima
di salutarci abbiamo veramente
mitragliato di domande me ne rendo conto
no no ma mi sono divertito tantissimo
c'è un messaggio che vorresti lanciare a
chi si sta ascoltando adesso magari
legato alla professione un messaggio no
però se siete
indecisi se pensate che questa questo
lavoro sia o vi potrebbe interessare
fatelo perché bellissima
grazie grazie
napoli c tua a volte succede sensi
perché non è che qui c'è la gente che
per questa serie a totò al casinò per
ragazzi il nostro viaggio all'interno
delle zone d'ombra dell'essere umano non
finisce qui per sedersi a un tavolo da
gioco bisogna avere qualcosa da perdere
eppure nel gioco della vita esistono
persone che partono senza alcune fasce
persone che per nascita la società già
bollato come sconfitte nella prossima
puntata di questo podcast parleremo con
uno di loro una persona che tra carcere
criminalità cocaina e violenza aveva già
scritto il proprio destino finché
qualcosa è cambiato da noi feroce e
tutto ragazzi e ragazze un grafico mondo
e di vivere dai
michele bravi
la digos calcistico
[Musica]